Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in
verses number 14- 19.
As a matter of fact, we will be more
focused on verses 15 and 16 due to their
subject matter. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala describes
the day of judgment in two places here
in this chapter.
The first one
he says
this is verse number 15.
He then describes it again and says
in verse number 17 he describes it in a
different way. In the first one, he
says, "The day when the earth and the
mountains will shake violently
and the mountains will be turned back to
running sand."
And in the second description he says
a day he describes the day of judgment
as a day when even infants and children
will become instantaneously grayhaired
due to the horrors and terror of that
day. Now
what's interesting about these two
verses
or one of the interesting things about
these two verses is that
there are how many blows into the into
the horn by who blows into the horn?
Huh? Is and is also one of the what?
H
we mentioned this back in
we mentioned
and we mentioned two main descriptions
for him or two main duties that he has.
Number one, he has been commissioned to
blow into the horn on the day of
judgment.
And number two, he is one of the
there's eight of them.
H
what is it? Say it loud, please.
He's one of the bears of the throne of
Allah. Very good, brother Jame. Sitting
in the cut, soaking it up a sponge.
Right. He he is one of the bearsers of
the throne. Eight.
So he is one of the eight bears of the
throne that carry the throne of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And he is also the
one that has been commissioned by Allah
to blow into the horn. Now
how many times will he blow into the
horn?
H two times it's al some scholars also
mentioned what three but the opinion of
the majority and the correct opinion is
that it is twice the first time to end
this world the second time to commence
the next world correct now he did both
of these
occasions are mentioned in this chapter
The first one he says in ver in verse
number 15.
He says the day describing the day of
judgment that it is the day
in which the earth
and the mountains upon it will shake.
violently
and the mountains will be running sand.
They will be rendered into a mound of
running sand. This is which blow into
the trumpet? The first or the second?
This is the first. This is destruction.
Correct.
Now the second he says
a day in which children
will turn gray
and witness to the horrors and the
fear of that day.
Correct. This is a description of which
blow into the trumpet.
The second
because the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentioned that and we will get
to that when we arrive at that verse
[Arabic recitation]
So both blows into the trumpet are me
into the horn are mentioned in this
chapter. the first in verse number 15
and the second in verse number 17. They
are alluded to in both of these
instances.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
describing the day of judgment.
Now I want you to take this description
of the day of judgment into account
in the context that it is mentioned
because the two previous verses Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions and
describes what he had prepared for the
disbelievers those who rejected the
message. Correct?
He says
he says indeed we have reserved for them
those disbelievers
restraints
and a furious raging fire
and food that will stick in the throats
and a very painful punishment on the day
in which the earth and the mountains
upon it will shake violently
will rumble violently
and the mountains
will be rendered to a mound of running
sand.
So why is this appropriate for this
context?
This is articulating to us
the
in the allencompassing
horror of the day of judgment. Why?
Because on the day of judgment,
there will be nothing
that a person can look to
to seek some kind of solace or peace in
some kind of reassurance
because everything will be different.
It will essentially be a day when up is
down and down is up. Allah mentions that
on that day people will be walking on
their faces.
People will be drowning in their own
sweat.
The sun its light will be put out and it
will be folded up.
That the people of wealth will abandon
their wealth. That the animals that are
wild will become domesticated on that
day etc etc. These are descriptions.
Why? What do these descriptions have in
common? They have in common that
everything that the human being seeks
solace in
that the human being is comforted by
will be no more on the day of judgment.
There will only be one comfort available
on the day of judgment. And that is the
comfort of what? the comfort of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. There will be no
more illusion of comfort anywhere else.
You'll look to the earth which the earth
is what makes it possible for us to live
on on this planet and its stability is
is a staple of our existence here. The
earth is stable.
We seek peace in that, comfort in that.
There is a rhythm to things. There is a
predictable nature to things. The sun
rises from the east. The sun sets in the
west. The earth is stable. The mountains
are solid. These are things that make
our existence give us some sense of
stability. Correct?
Why? there's a narration
in Sah
Bkari
in which the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentions that
the the sun will rise from the west one
day and when the people see it rise from
the west they will all believe
immediately and entirely every last one
of them.
But that is a day when belief is not
going to be accepted anymore. Why is it
that that singular
change in the rhythm of life on this
planet
influences people so strongly to all
believe suddenly to abandon their egos
to abandon their agendas to abandon
their arguments and believe.
The reason is, can you imagine how
terrifying
and jarring it is for something as
stable as the sunrise to change?
This this will make a person unhinged.
Suicide is very prevalent
in the very northern regions of the
world where the sun doesn't set for
months on end.
and where the sun goes away for six or
seven months at a time. It's nighttime
for six months, right? People go crazy
because they start to lose faith in the
rhythm and stability of the world around
us. that chaotic that chaos of
unpredictability
that will cause a person to
become incredibly terrified. So
imagine now that the earth which is our
stable platform now is no longer stable.
It is doing the exact opposite of what
we expect it to do. It is constantly
moving. It is shaking. You cannot plant
your feet on it because it is shaking
violently.
And the mountains which are a paragon of
stability and a symbol of stability
now become what? Running sand
underneath your feet. A mound of running
sand underneath your feet. The
description that the pro that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gives he says
even the rhythm of the syllables in the
verse articulate
a kind of movement.
You hear that rhythm? That is a rhythm
that reflects the movement and the
violence of the day of judgment.
And for this reason, Allah describes the
day of judgment elsewhere. He says,
He says, "When the day comes that the
horn is blown into
everyone in the heavens and the earth
will be taken with shock and terror that
will paralyze them." The prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam described in Bkari
that when the horn is blown, people will
be in the middle of their movements.
He describes a man selling a piece of
fabric,
handing it over to the customer. And he
describes a customer handing over
the money for that piece of fabric. And
suddenly they are interrupted by
the blow into the horn. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says and they will
freeze in place from what? From the
terror.
This one will be unable to drop or or
retract what is in his hand and the
other as well. They will freeze in place
immediately as soon as the blow into the
horn reaches their ears. The prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam says that on the
day of judgment,
he describes certain people on the
earth.
And he says, "One man will be on the
outskirts of Medina
with his flock of animals, whether it be
sheep or goats or cows or whatever it
is, his herd. and he will be trying to
get his herd to behave and his herd will
be acting wild. You know how animals
sense when something is off? You know
how animals go against their nature when
something is off?
And he will find his animals have turned
into wild beasts.
And a man will be preparing
the trough for his camel when suddenly
the horn is blown and they will freeze
in place and they will be taken by a
black terror.
And that is the day when the earth will
shake and jostle violently
and the mountains will be rendered into
a mound of running sand.
Listen to the description.
[Silence]
And the mountains.
which when we look at them, we draw from
them consciously or subconsciously,
we draw from them
a sense of stability. When we look at
the mountains, no matter how bad life
gets, right? No matter how random
tragedy may seem, how are we able to
keep our sanity? And I'm not speaking
about Muslims. Muslims, we are
anchored in our belief in Allah.
That's where we find our stability.
But we look to the mountains, we see a
symbol of stability.
We feel the earth underneath our feet
and we see it as a symbol of stability.
Down is still down. Up is still up.
mountains are still standing. There is
hope. But what happens when those things
change?
What happens to that hope when the
mountains turn into the antithesis of
stability
and now the mountains are running sand?
Where before they were solid, now they
are fluid.
And the earth was stable and now it is
nothing but movement under your feet.
How then can a person find any hope in
such a situation?
There is no hope except in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so the
believers
whilst they may be scared,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes them
saying
he says subhanahu
[Silence]
He says those believers essentially
they will not be stricken with grief on
the day of the great terror.
And the angels will receive them and
they will assure them. These are the
believers. The disbelievers.
Listen to the difference in description.
On the day when the earth and the
mountains will shake violently and
incessantly
and the mountains will be rendered into
a mound of running sandal.
[Arabic recitation]
Jesus.
What's your name?
[Arabic recitation]
guess. Don't tell me. Don't tell me.